y nos dicen un estudiante construye un
circuito con una batería y dos resistor
es en serie la resistencia r 2 es el
doble que la resistencia r 1 abajo se
muestra la gráfica de la energía perdida
por r 1 a lo largo del tiempo esta
gráfica que tenemos a la izquierda cuál
de las siguientes muestra la energía
perdida en r 2 a lo largo del tiempo en
términos de e
y tenemos estas cuatro opciones pausa el
vídeo e intenta descubrirlo por tu
cuenta
ok vamos a trabajar juntos primero
visualicemos el circuito esta es nuestra
batería por lo tanto esta es la terminal
positiva y esta es la negativa y después
tenemos en nuestro primer resistor
después a nuestro segundo resistor y nos
dicen que estos resistor es están en
serie
este será r 1 y este r 2 ahora si
tenemos un circuito como éste donde
ninguna parte está en paralelo la
corriente que fluye a lo largo del
circuito será constante por lo tanto
podemos decir que para cualquier punto
en el circuito la corriente que
llamaremos y es constante también nos
dicen cómo están relacionadas estas
resistencias si suponemos que el 1 tiene
una resistencia de no sea x oms nos
dicen que la resistencia en r2 es el
doble que la resistencia en r1 por lo
tanto si eres uno tiene una resistencia
de x oms
r2 tendrá una resistencia de 2x oms
ahora pensemos si esta es la gráfica de
la energía que se disipa a través de r
a lo largo del tiempo cuál será la
energía que se disipará a través de r2 a
lo largo del tiempo para eso pensemos en
términos de potencia y energía y lo que
conocemos de ellas
sabemos que la potencia es la energía
disipada sobre el tiempo por ejemplo
podemos escribir que la potencia es
igual a la energía disipada sobre el
tiempo y podemos verlo como el cambio en
el voltaje a través del resistor por la
corriente a través de él si queremos una
expresión de la energía total disipada
en el tiempo podemos fijarnos en esta
parte de aquí podríamos multiplicar
ambos lados por delta t por lo tanto
podemos escribir que la energía disipada
es igual al cambio de voltaje a través
del resistor por la corriente que pasa a
través del resistor por el cambio en el
tiempo
ahora bien si empezamos ente igual a
cero nuestro cambio en el tiempo será el
tiempo en el que nos fijemos menos cero
entonces tendremos cualquier tiempo en
el que estemos por lo tanto escribiré t
en lugar de delta de t ahora el cambio
de voltaje a través del resistor ya lo
hemos visto antes será el valor de la
corriente que fluye por ese resistor por
la resistencia por lo tanto si tomamos
esta información y sustituimos por delta
b en nuestra primera expresión que
obtenemos obtendremos que la energía
disipada será igual a la corriente que
fluye a través del resistor por la
resistencia por la corriente que fluye a
través del resistor por el tiempo o
podemos escribir que la energía disipada
como una función de estas tres variables
será la corriente al cuadrado por la
resistencia por el tiempo
ahora bien gracias a la gráfica dada
sabemos que el t1 tenemos una energía
disipada de
eso con una resistencia de x oms por lo
tanto podemos decir que la energía
disipada 1 es igual a cuadrada por x
esa es la resistencia por d 1
ahora pensemos en cuál será la energía
disipada en t1 pero en nuestro segundo
resistor si regresamos a nuestra
expresión original la energía disipada
será igual a tf1 por la corriente que
como sabemos es la misma corriente que
fluye por ambos resistor es ya que
recuerda están en serie por lo tanto
tenemos la misma corriente y cuadrada y
ahora cuál es la resistencia bueno en
lugar de x tenemos 2x así que podemos
escribir esto como 2 por y cuadrada por
x por t 1
ahora observa esto que tenemos aquí era
justo la misma cantidad de energía que
se disipaban en el tiempo de uno en
nuestro primer resistor esto es
por lo tanto en t1 la energía disipada
en nuestro segundo resistor será el
doble entonces lo que queremos observar
es que para tf1 tengamos el doble de
energía disipada esta gráfica de abajo
solo tiene un cuarto de la energía
disipada en definitiva no es lo que
buscamos y podemos cancelar la esta de
arriba es la mitad de la energía que
buscamos por lo tanto también voy a
cancelar la esta gráfica a la derecha
tiene la misma cantidad de energía por
lo tanto no es lo que buscamos y puedo
cancelarla y aquí en t1 tenemos el doble
de energía disipada por lo tanto esta es
la opción que buscábamos
otra forma de pensarlo es que si tenemos
la misma corriente que fluye a través de
los dos resistor es el segundo resistor
tiene el doble de resistencia que el
primero entonces en cualquier tiempo
dado